[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
hi how are you on your way to work maybe
on your way home from work
this is a hello right to you straight to
you
i hope uh you enjoyed today's show
i hope you're uh smiling right now i
hope that you had a good day or you're
gonna have a good day
and uh you know
trying to be present right now trying to
be present
ryan you okay you're good i'm checking
everything checking out
the lights uh okay yeah everything looks
see everything
everything seems to look okay i got a
haircut nice
yeah got a haircut and uh i got
vaccinated
congratulations thank you i got the
johnson and johnson the one shot that
was it
the girl behind me got um i was
perfectly fine
nothing nothing happened to me not a
not fatigued not nauseous nothing it's
been
uh quite some time now so i'm not gonna
would not nothing's happening
just a one and done i didn't really want
to do the other one i guess they're all
they're all pretty good but uh still got
to be safe and stuff but
uh feels it kind of feels good to be
vaccinated you feel relieved
uh yeah i i do feel relieved
it doesn't fix everything but it fixes
something yeah my arm's not even sore
really no it might even it it's less
than a mosquito bite
nice just nothing i got lucky i think
gracious lord uh thanks for everybody
who tuned in to the stage at show and
watched my band play
rob and i had a great uh great day uh my
band's son spin we played on stage we
played two shows this last saturday and
gave a lot of prizes and zooms we zoomed
a lot of people and
thank you everyone for being there and
supporting the band you're always so
amazing a big shout out to all the
patrons
who do that if you want to follow the
band
you can go to sunspin.com we got lunch
boxes and merch and all sorts of fun
stuff and
you could book the band if you'd like
you could book a zoom with the band
sunspin.com handles are at sunspin band
everywhere and uh also the inside of you
online store got a bunch of stuff i
think we still got some
lex luthor shirts and autograph pictures
and uh
other shirts and just lots of great
stuff on there it's the inside of you
online store
uh we should probably give a discount
code we did uh we did ryan
15 last time didn't we was inside of
yeah inside of ryan yeah
inside ryan inside of ryan 15. right so
maybe
you know uh inside ryan
do we dare go 20 that's that's kind of a
lot that's a lot it's a big percent
you know what effort 20 off everything
in the store but this is only going to
be for
until tomorrow wednesday so get it while
you can
20 off everything in the inside of you
online store inside of
ryan 20. inside of ryan or inside bro
sorry inside ryan there we go 20. there
we go
20 off hey thank you guys for tuning in
i know a lot of guests uh come and
people listen they want to listen to
those guests and they then tune out
but uh you know we're a podcast that
could use your help
you know we use your listening skills
and uh if you dug this if you like it
then we hope you stick around
and um you know sign on subscribe uh
where can they subscribe ryan uh
inside of youpod on twitter inside of
you podcast on instagram and facebook
youtube.com inside of you with michael
rosen it's all right here
yep see it's all right here if you're
watching but
uh please subscribe please subscribe and
get your friends to subscribe
it truly helps and try to listen to
every episode we try to give you
something interesting
interesting guests great guest today rob
benedict richard spate
uh these guys incredible incredible
stories that they tell
their their dad's stories of being a dad
but you might know these guys
from supernatural uh they're both
musicians
uh we've we've played together uh
they're fantastic guys i really enjoyed
talking with them it's a good one it was
one of my favorites for sure really
now that says a lot ryan doesn't um
usually come out and say that i usually
have to ask him did you like it i really
did yeah yeah
yeah sometimes you have really great
conversations with people and you learn
a lot and
this some of their stories were just
fascinating and one in particular
about uh richard saving uh rob's life
so without further ado let's get inside
rob benedict and richard spate
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
rob benedict how's it going buddy i love
that you have a gold microphone
why is that cause you're just gold i
don't know i just i thought it looked
cool
well you are cool is that a head in the
back that's
it's my head it's my head from uh
from the uh our our kings of con show
that rich and i did
right that's right i want to get into
that and richard spate now
uh who's richard spate jr god forbid i
just call him richard spate
but he'll be on in just a minute he's
having a conversation with a teacher did
he get in trouble what's the deal there
yeah i don't know uh sounds you know it
sounds serious
but uh i don't know right something you
know he's got three boys
he's got three boys so uh you know at
any one time
one of them is getting into trouble oh
wait a minute so it is
is it a serious talk with the teacher
about his his children
i don't know i don't know how serious it
is um but yeah
he's just having a conversation with the
teacher we're going to find out is what
we're going to do we're going to it's
not necessarily you know a bad thing but
it can't be great it can't be great if
i'm being honest you know it's
yeah who has an hour conversation zoom
with a teacher if it's great
like hey i just want to catch up just
tell your kids are great
uh fantastic uh let's go from every
course math aces across the board
uh just really power and through uh
speech class
uh very confident uh no farting
uh doing a lot of good for this uh this
high school
yeah and does the teacher not have other
classes that's my other thought you know
is
yeah is she he or she just sort of
skipping the other classes to have this
long talk about
speaking what teacher has an hour to
spare with
one parent i don't have an hour and why
isn't his
wife on the meeting with him is it just
him it might be just him his wife works
and she she works she has a crazy job
and works
uh long hours either that or maybe old
dick spate junior is the disciplinarian
here it could be i mean it is he is
he is the disciplinarian those kids do
not mess around when he's
he's home were you a good kid in school
yeah i was a good kid i was a good kid i
i um yeah i i figured out early my
brother was an
athlete star athlete and i when i went
to high school i realized okay i didn't
have anything to offer in that realm
so school became my
what i did well you know you excelled
i excelled yeah i was a good kid and
[ __ ] was going on at home
so what [ __ ] wait you can't just say
throw that away you can't say [ __ ] was
going on at home i might have talked
about it last time i was on your show
but you know my dad
left uh was kind of like uh spending
time between my house and his uh
mistress's house uh mistresses plural
no one just one mistress right and i was
maybe 12
and uh uh and then eventually that sort
of became
sort of the mistress got most the time
and and he just kind of didn't come back
oh yeah yeah so it was rough by the time
i got to high school was rough my mom
was in a bad
dark place and my siblings were gone i'm
the youngest of four
and it was me my mom and so i just i
don't know some kids
rebel at high school like for me i was
like
[ __ ] it i'm gonna do you know i'm just
gonna work as hard as i can and be just
the best student and being
the president of everything and you know
what i mean involved in everything and
just just overdo it
so that that's that was high school for
me how do you have that much
what's the word when you now i guess
hindsight uh
no uh well how do you just how do you
know
as you have to be pretty emotionally
smart
or aware that to make a conscious
decision like that to
to go oh i this is [ __ ] up i'm gonna
do something really good with my life
whereas i was hanging by a thread
my entire school like oh yeah just like
you know i am not going to make it
i always say i i've talked about this
but i always say i have had and i don't
know if death wish is the right term but
i i just never thought i'd live past
grade school high school
college i never i always thought yeah
and i just
uh i just i didn't have that emotional
support at home and it sounds like you
know maybe you didn't either was your
mother
i i'll get to that but how did you yeah
how did you make that decision that
you're going to do well and you're going
to excel and get out
how do you do that i don't know my mom
talks about it she said literally we had
a conversation after my first day of
high school and i was like
this is what i'm going to do it was it
was my brother's 6'4
and he's like he was like the basketball
star
i was the opposite of that i came in and
i i knew what i you know i knew i was a
a smart kid and i could do i really
wanted to have that
achievement like he had and i guess i
just made that conscious decision to go
you know this is going to be what i do
and i think it too when you're that age
you know i have teenagers now and when
they're that age like
and i you know i've been through a
divorce now and and my
my children are teenagers and i see them
do it in a way that
you almost you you you hang on to what
you can control
almost obsessively i can control that
and for me i could control
i could control that i just i i was
smart enough that i was like i can
i can control this i can get good grades
and and be a
you know a good kid where it got me in
trouble is that like i got obsessed
about people liking me
it was weird yeah i guess about like
really wanting to be liked and doing
whatever i could just to be
liked which kind of had this weird thing
to do with like
you know my dad being gone and my world
kind of being exploded
so i was just i was just like are you
mad at me don't be mad at me are you mad
at me
do you feel do you feel like there's
part of that in you still that little
kid who just wants to be liked
100 percent we don't lose that i've
always just
i just when i walk into a room it's not
like people say oh you're so confident i
think it's because i'm not confident
i want people to like me and accept me
and i'm like how do i make them like me
because i don't feel like
how i'm i can't be likable you know i'm
me i still have that image of myself as
this young
punk who i just didn't feel that was you
know
necessarily loved or liked by by a lot
of people and so
that's a hard thing to lose but you like
your your father
and your mother they did they show
affection
to you um my mom did yeah my dad wasn't
there but my mom did
i didn't have that i never had that male
uh energy around because he wasn't
around but uh but my mom
my mom was affectionate well how does
that make you uh like
does that put so much pressure on you to
be the best father ever and
are you hard on yourself about being a
father a little bit you know a little
bit and certainly going through
um the separation and then divorce was
tough for me
because i did you know i just i've
worked extra hard to not be my dad
so yeah i mean i i do i i overachieve at
being a father too and i have to you
know be careful not to
you know they get to a point where
they're like we got it we're good
you can stand down you know listen guys
i always feel like if i was a father
i would be like look i love you
i want you to tell me everything that
you need to
if you want to you could share anything
with me i've been through it all i've
embarrassed myself
i have been a big [ __ ] up in my life um
and i want you to know that if you do
something stupid you can come to me i'm
not gonna
hit you you don't hit kids anymore okay
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna you know i want you to
know that you can come to me i might get
mad at you i might be disappointed but
like
we could work things out and i want you
to know that i'm here because a lot of
kids i don't think that they feel like
their parents are there
right no and that that's that's me i
mean that's my relationship with my
my kids my son has become you know he's
he's such a good kid he's just a really
good kid he tells me everything
we're just buddies and he'll tell me
anything that's he's 17.
does he tell you about uh sex does he
say
you know does he say dad you know i got
a handy what does he do
yeah i mean he'll you know uh yeah he
you know uh he's not having sex but he
but he has a girlfriend and and you know
i get the i get
so much so sometimes i'm like you don't
need to i don't need to know that you
can you know
you can have that one for yourself like
what will he say like what would he say
i'm embarrassed because i don't want him
to like hear this good
see my mom never did that my mom would
write articles in her small town paper
and embarrass me
on a daily basis and she would flirt
with other men in front of me and she
would all do she always embarrassed
and i think the big thing is don't
embarrass your kids like
let them be them don't try to interfere
uh but like look like i said i i have
two dogs
and uh i do the best i can but i'm like
i [ __ ] could barely
you know handle two dogs how could i
ever be a father of a
of a human being yeah that's yeah and
when when you go through this like
divorce and all this stuff
did you think you were gonna be married
forever did you think you know i'm never
gonna leave this woman
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah without question
we were married for 24 years
so it wasn't your call it was all of a
sudden one day she wakes up and says
oh uh yeah i'm done it was complicated
it was complicated it was kind of many
years in the making
we have very separate lives and our our
paths were going
uh in opposite directions and um
it was kind of like you know lots of
years of therapy and and
finally just you know it's i think we
both just kind of threw the towel in
and i you know we realized we were both
not happy
is it hard to like when your heart's
broken to
not share that with your kids and try to
be strong is there a balancing act you
have to do yeah and that was a thing you
know at first it was it was like it's
you know we're fine we're working it out
it's you know
we're gonna try living apart for a
little bit but we're working you know
and then finally they were like
just talk to us what's going on you know
they were the ones that sort of like
called it and so you know that's when
molly and i had to both be
very honest with them about what's going
on and and it sent our relationship into
a whole different
realm too in a good way really so now
you can have conversations and it's
amicable and
and and it's okay everything's okay now
yeah yeah we you know we
her and i get along really well and we
all four hang out
and we have family nights together you
know so we still have that i think
that's really important
are you still attracted to her do you
ever think maybe we can get back
together or something you kind of like
you know you like let that go i kind of
let that go
um but she's uh you know she's like
family to me i mean i've known her for
um you know um my half my life and uh
i mean we started dating almost 30 years
ago
and we were married for 24 years like
you know you don't you don't just let
that go
that doesn't go away so i love her and
she'll always be like family to me
that's awesome you're a tough guy that'd
be really tough i mean
uh you know who's here to break up this
conversation speaking of tough guys this
is richard spade jr is just joining the
conversation
we were getting deep boy we were getting
deep fast
dude yeah so wait richard before you get
going first of all
you've got no facial hair we'll get into
that i've never seen you without facial
hair
b uh you know i thought you were doing a
zoom call with some uh
teacher for some magazine or something i
didn't realize you were
having a disciplinarian meeting uh with
a teacher about your children
yes it's it's uh this is a full school
day any day of the week
uh in lockdown is a full school day at
uh
dick junior school for the blonde i have
three students
and uh i am fully charged with um
proctoring their education which so far
is going
just great okay something there's
sarcasm he's laying
on us pretty thick there uh rob i'm just
not i mean listen man i
i love teachers i i admire teachers i do
not necessarily have the patience and
the skill
i love spending time with my boys that's
great but i'd be lying if i didn't say
they're not gonna lose a few
steps this last year and a half because
i'm not
i'm not great i'm i'm i'm there i'm
present i try to drive the
keep the ball moving forward and all
that good stuff but you know
what are some of the issues like that a
parent has to deal with for instance
like is it
for me it was he won't shut the [ __ ] up
okay there's
s's satisfactory there's s minuses
then there's uh i's i believe there were
i don't remember what eyes were and then
they were used
unsatisfactory i was always a you dying
to know what the eyes were
i think the eyes were indifferent
uh i'm at a loss maybe it stood for yeah
i quit i quit i i got paddled as a kid
i remember there's this kid bruce holder
in our school who they had paddling
corporal punishment
i haven't heard that word in a while and
i remember uh he was gonna get paddled
because he did something and he fainted
in the hallway
i don't know whatever happened but he
fainted and they they took him to the
nurse's office and then the the teacher
called his mom and said uh hi mrs holder
uh your son uh said the f-bomb and did
something else and he we were gonna
paddle him and he fainted and she says
well when his ass wakes up paddle him
that was it so different mentality i
grew up in southern indiana
you you gave a kid a smack if he did
something wrong every once in a while
things are different decades baby right
you know so what is it
dick spate junior what is it now it's
different because you know you
we're talking about lockdown school so
the issue
with um what kids
are navigating is very different than
in classroom learning because you know i
know
this from dealing with my own children i
also know this from talking to
friends of mine who are teachers and
that is
kids just kept and walk away it's not
you know you wouldn't get up and leave
class
but you get up and walk away from a
screen it's hard to keep their attention
and keep them
engaged and keep them present literally
physically present
they can shut their camera off they can
be doing a little text chain that no
one's aware of down here to the right
they could have a second second computer
or second
window open on their computer and be
watching david dobrik youtube videos
and not watching that quest porn's hard
to do on the school computer those
google viewers are
logged are kind of built to that have
that not it's more that they're talking
to their friends at the same time
right right right right right there or
are playing a game but at my house the
uh the teenagers are uh it's more like
during school hours like
i'm like the uh i'm the sh i'm the cook
i make the lunches i get them up but
they're like then they're like get out
of my room like
i can't knock if they're in the class
like dad i'm in class like i have to
you know kind of stay away but rich
rich's youngest is what nine eight or
nine
nine yeah how do you know he's jesus
rich has to be more hands-on
how do you have how do you for me i you
know
it's like you know i talked to do you
have a propensity
big word for me to just uh hang out with
people who have kids
like the both of you because for me i
have i can relate to somebody like my
friend rob it's like oh my dog
[ __ ] all over the house today he's like
oh [ __ ] dude but like do you feel like
you need to relate to somebody who has
children too so is that why you guys get
along i know you've been friends a long
time but
demo are most of your friends married
kids are those people you sort of relate
more to is that why
when people get girlfriends and wives
and kids they stop hanging out with the
single loser
like i'll tell you something i think
largely our social group
um certainly the social group we share
through rob's band and through
supernatural and all that stuff
almost everybody's married with kids or
have gotten married
in the time we've known each other but i
actually think it's not that i
i think when you have kids you're
immediately like so long single
lamos off to the married club we go i
think
i think your entire life schedule shifts
it's like if you're a
hog farmer you're not hanging out with
the night dj because you're up at four
feeding animals like the the idea that
your life has changed so dramatically
the dog
farmer throws you onto a schedule
right right that is different so i have
single buddies
and they'll go like you want to grab a
beer i'm like yeah i'd love to where are
you going to be like
let's meet at uh blah blah blah nine
nine
ain't nowhere how about how about a diet
soda at the counter at four
i'm just like if my taillights aren't
aimed home by nine if if i go to sleep
and there's not a nine
in front of the hour my day the next day
is
effed you know because it's just i
remember my when my sister
i have two older sisters i remember my
oldest sister barbie got married and had
her first
uh kid and barbie was always super fun
and social
and i went to visit her in alexandria
virginia where she was living with her
uh her husband and her new new baby or
you know toddler
and she's like all right well let's have
dinner and i'm like
it's six he said yeah that's when we
dinner i'm like
who on god's green earth eats dinner at
six
let's let's eat dinner at nine let's do
like my mind was still in that
and she and she was saying nine well go
enjoy your dinner because
we're feeding the kids in our will be
god willing asleep by nine
and i thought that was loony and then of
course decades later i had my own kids
and i
i was like oh oh yeah okay
inside of you is brought to you by
athletic greens i love these guys
because i'm lazy as crap
do you understand ryan you know how many
people say oh well you need to take this
vitamin for this
you need to take this mineral for that
you need to have a bowl of bran
eat it i don't want to do it i'm tired
of it so
this guy developed this product athletic
greens it's all in a powder
you just pour it in i know you had this
and i know you liked it because you
would tell me and i wouldn't ask you if
you didn't like it no it's good
yes it's delicious and you drink a glass
in the morning
it makes me feel dynamite and it gives
me so much
tell us what's in there one tasty scoop
of athletic greens contains
75 vitamins minerals and whole
food-sourced ingredients including a
multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic greens superfood
blend and more and they all work
together
to fill the nutritional gaps in your
diet
they increase energy and focus aid with
digestion and support
a healthy immune system all without the
need to take
multiple products and right now athletic
greens is doubling down and supporting
your immune system
during these next few months they are
offering my audience a free
one-year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase
if you visit my link today you'll
basically never have to buy vitamin d
again so whether you're looking for peak
performance or better health
covering your bases with athletic greens
makes investing in your energy
immunity and gut health each day simple
tasty and efficient simply visit
athleticgreens.com
y o u and join health experts
athletes and health conscious go-getters
around the world
who make a daily commitment to their
health every day
again simply visit athleticgreens.com
y-o-u and get your free year supply of
vitamin d
in five free travel packs today
insidei is brought to you by nitza i
don't know about you but i'm one
impatient mofo
i uh you know you're driving your
freaking car ryan
yep and you hit the train tracks right
you hit the train tracks the lights are
going and you're like
there's no train here i could just get
through there it's to say you know
i don't have time for this don't do it
trust me you have time
your life has time it can be frustrating
i know especially you know you're in a
hurry
you're late you find yourself at a
railway crossing waiting for a train
and if the signals are going and the
train's not even there yet
you get that feeling you're a bit
tempted to try and sneak across the
tracks
well don't ever to the naked eye trains
often appear to be further away and
moving slower than they are
and they can't stop quickly even if the
engineer hits the emergency brakes right
away
it can take a train over a mile to stop
over a mile to stop by that time it's
too late and the result is a potentially
deadly crash the point is you can't know
how quickly the train will arrive
the train can't stop quickly even if it
sees you it ends
in disaster if the signals are on the
train is on its way and you
just need to remember one thing stop
trains can't inside of you is brought to
you by better help
better help online therapy folks don't
fast forward this uh this message could
probably save your life
it could probably save you a lot of
stress and um
all the crap that we feel all all the
time non-stop
depression anxiety um ryan
have you ever had therapy i did once a
long time ago i think i'm going to start
again though
why would you start again uh because i
don't feel like my brain is right
i think that is just a very honest
answer
uh i i feel that's why you know i feel
like my brain's not right and for a long
time i was like i don't need therapy i
don't need this and i thought i was
indestructible and then
i realized i was just uh you know
bottling all this
bad stuff up over the years and trying
to be superman you know pun
intended and i just you got to do what's
best for you
you got to do what's best for your body
and your mind and you know a lot of
people are closed off to therapy and
it's a shame because i think they'll see
how much you could really help them and
how much it's helped me
of course what is therapy exactly well
you know ryan it's
anything you want it to be you know but
what's great for me is it gives me the
tools to help with
motivation uh depression anxiety but it
can also help people who are battling
their temper stress dealing with
insecurity in relationships or at work
it's time to stop being ashamed of your
normal human struggles and start feeling
better because
you deserve to be happy better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to
i like to see my therapist hey what's
going on sandy
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and trust me when i say it it's
way more affordable these guys are so
much cheaper than if you go to
somebody in la or you know you go to a
private practice you're going to be
spending a lot more money
much more affordable and you can start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about
it may or may not be for you but it's
worth looking into
because you are your greatest asset
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and inside of you listeners get ten
percent off their first month
at betterhelp.com inside
that's betterhelp.com
slash inside i
look at you guys and i think of course
these two should have children they're
grounded
they're lovely human beings and that's
why i
gauge like whether i would be a good
father i just
think that it's a mistake i think the
child will be a mistake
i think not a mistake but i think
i will kill myself trying to be
something
because i will never be as look i always
have this
issue with trying to be great at
everything and i'm working on that
because
you can't be especially as a father
you're gonna make mistakes you're gonna
you know and uh you know i definitely
don't want them to follow in my
footsteps
i want them to be secure and loved and
and feel like
so i mean are you i talked to to robbie
about this but like are you
do you feel like you uh do you make a
lot of big mistakes are you hard on
yourself or are you just kind of
easygoing and let things
kind of flow i'm not easygoing i'm i'm
the
hard opposite of easygoing and i make a
shitload of mistakes
but i don't think you can parent and not
make mistakes because it's not an exact
science
it simply isn't you don't know the
personality of the child you're going to
have you don't know what's going to work
or not work with that child
and then if you have another child say
you get in a groove with old number one
here comes number two with a whole
different set of criteria not the same
same parts not the same journey to the
child
and i'll say something to piggyback on
something you said
about like you think you'd you know
screw it up because you are
right now a man who is not
teamed up with somebody that you want to
enter this venture adventure with
like i think a lot of having children
for me
and i would love to hear rob's two cents
on this although i think i know what
he's gonna say
was i i outputted my coverage when it
came to
marrying somebody with attributes and
qualities that i admire
so the idea of teaming up with her to
have kids
i'm like we can do this sort of like all
right neither one of us know what we're
doing
but you liked your family i liked my
family and i like you and you like me
let's give this a go
and there's something very much like
rah-rah about it
that's part of the fun adventure and
challenge of having kids is the team
team element of it i mean i can't
imagine being a single dad i never have
been
uh knock on wood and a single mom even
harder
i i can't imagine that journey but for
me
being happily married
to somebody i admire and and when i see
attributes of her in my children i think
good
thank god they pulled that from my wife
that's great
yeah rob you want to take that one yeah
you know for me
it's a little bit uh different now
because like i said i've been through
this kind of life change
and um i find myself for the first time
uh parenting solo half the time the kids
are with me and i'm i'm by myself with
them
certainly yeah i mean and like to what i
was saying earlier like that's why
my ex-wife and i still have such a great
relationship because
the children were created out of love
and our our joint
uh desire to do this together you know
and that just doesn't go away um
so certainly yeah that was the reason i
had kids it was the same thing i was
scared
scared shitless uh especially because of
what happened with my dad and i didn't
you know when i found out my firstborn
was going to be a son i was like holy
christ i don't know how to
i don't know how what it is to be a
father you know i mean i don't have
anything any reference for being a
father
um and uh you know and another buddy of
mine was like well that's probably why
you're having a
son so you can figure that out right
you know but but but now i find myself
sort of in this sort of new
world in terms of fortunately i've got
two really good kids they're
teenagers they you know uh they're
really like
you know buddies that i need to feed
friends that i need to feed well
yeah let me ask you this what was if
it's not too personal you know
how i get personal that's my middle name
but like
who is there for you to console you when
this all went down when you did get
divorced and you had to go through this
[ __ ]
who did you turn to and were you a mess
uh yeah i had a really rough
uh couple years um and i was you know
um yeah i was a bit out of control
and uh you know i had friends like like
rich
um i have this other group of uh uh
dudes that i know that actually are are
not married
um and and they they were there for me
because it's hard because a lot of my
friends that are married they have their
own [ __ ] going on
um but rich was in the rich was in the
trenches with me and
and and certainly helped me a lot um
and and then i've got this other group
of friends that are dudes that that are
in their 40s but not like you mike and
never married and uh they were there too
and just friends man just friends but it
was hard it was really hard
you guys are it seems like you're
inseparable you've done so much work
together you've known each other how
long
oh right 13 years or so probably i mean
at this point yeah we've known of each
other for probably
20 years but but we're friends you know
14 years did you meet on supernatural
well that's
a see there's a story there because
i have seen rob benedict's work on on
television and in film
and thought he was a really talented guy
and he's one of those dudes that i would
see at auditions right because we're
kind of the same category
yeah of guy both hunters yeah both
and it would be us it'd be dean kane you
know the youth
for huge
so like we're like uh i'd cross mama's
path a lot and
i'm one of those dudes like and rob
knows this about me like if i if i liked
you in something
i there's no ego i will walk up and be
like god just watch an episode of tv you
run you just knocked this i'm like that
i do that too all the time yeah and some
actor like i was
i like that guy but i don't want to show
my hand yeah i don't want to say that i
liked it because then you know
next time we're in the audition room
he'll think like he's got me
[Laughter]
oh man i'm a big fan and the joke is and
it's
obviously been blown up over time for a
comedic effect but in truth
rob would forget that we had met so i
would go up to him like
rob benedict rich faye
saw you and blah blah blah man that was
just great
oh thanks thanks man thanks yeah no
seriously like really good ah
yeah yeah thanks thanks buddy thanks and
you know
on our merry way we go then i go to a
pilot taping a buddy of mine wrote
and there's rob it's one of the regulars
and i come down afterwards i'm like
robin
oh my god rich fate look at you like
yeah
yeah thanks man um
then after two it became
like i ran into him on halloween well we
were doing supernatural we were
overlapping we weren't we were not
working in the same episodes but i would
see rob
like he was on the call sheet for the
next episode so we'd overlap and we'd
overlap in the apartment i remember like
oh
benedict's moving in here after i leave
so i'd leave like a funny outgoing
message like this is rob benedict's
apartment you've reached me i'm in the
shower it could be hours
you know it's back back before we had
everybody we actually had land lines in
the apartments
somebody shut their dog up lunas
luna barks luna barks at friendlies
cuddles up to the enemy
i almost yelled at my dog shut up but
they're not doing anything
it's fine um but so i run into robin
trick-or-treating he's out with his kids
two kids like they're cut out of
magazines i'm chasing my kids around
hurting them with a rake and robbie
he's there and i'm like rob
hey rich spade he goes and he goes hey
hey man
with that look of i don't know who you
are you know that
clear like glazed over i'm like rich
spate supernatural you know medical
times
supernatural and he's like ah yeah no
hey hey
uh good to see you buddy good i'm gonna
you know go with
these better looking kids but i'll be
you know thanks for stopping
with these better looking kids all
lettuce that led up to this time
i was at the grove no
[Laughter]
i'm out with my special lady friend my
wife the machete
and we go up to the bar at the arclight
to have a cocktail before
these screening and if you know that
area it's a small s
you know slender bar area and a couple
of cocktail tables
and we sat down at one end and at the
far end i see
a young rob benedict and his wife molly
out for a date night themselves
and i'm like oh there's there's that guy
rob benedict and his wife
on a date night me and i go to the bar
and i order a drink
and he goes hey are you that guy from
supernatural i'm like yeah yeah that guy
and he looked over he goes isn't that
guy also from supernatural
yeah yeah that's rob benedict who's also
in supernatural and the guy's like oh
why aren't you guys talking to each
other let's
he never remembers me man i just i'm
done please
please say he came up to you please i
didn't see him
you didn't know what was that man i
didn't see you i just i just i couldn't
find any bartender
i didn't see him i remember see
my side of that whole story is that i
remember rich bait rich bait was really
uh he booked like 80 000 commercials
back in the day and so
when i used to do a lot of commercial
auditions he was always
in the waiting room and i remember like
if he was there
you're [ __ ] like he he had the job but
so i just kind of knew who he was and he
was also just really nice and he was a
nice guy so
you know you couldn't hate on him um so
i just kind of knew his face
i remember meeting him at that pilot
taping and i remember him at halloween i
had
actually two young children beauty
beautiful as they may be there as you
well know rich a lot of work
so it was a little more like oh hey yeah
hey man i got to run with the kids hey
nice seeing you all right it wasn't
enough for all richie
wasn't enough i remember you looked at
my kids you go those are your kids
oh that's not sorry who are you who are
you richard spate
hey uh that's amazing so
yeah i mean the first time you guys hung
out was it on supernatural though i mean
actually hung out and you were like
conventions it was conventional
conventions yeah so you do these
conventions
with jensen and jared the supernatural
things
and you know our friends jason mann's
there and you start
you're playing music together and also
no richard you're both signing because
you're
actors on the show yeah at this point
there was no musical component to the
conventions this is early early on
there's no band there's no i mean rob
had a band but there was no band playing
the conventions it was
kind of the old model of walk on do your
30 minute panel
to a smattering of applause walk off go
sit at your table you know
kind of move through the system like
that there was not a lot of interaction
between the character between the actors
right
my band actually did a one-off concert
at one of the conventions in burbank
it was a one-off thing and richard came
to the show which was
cool because normally the actors take
off um
back in the day they went and uh came to
the show and stood in line
at our autograph session so he could say
hey to the band which i thought was a
very humble thing for this guy
rich spade jr remember from the the
restaurant and the
yeah and the other five times
now you're inseparable and it's like how
did this relationship really i mean in a
nutshell you don't have to talk about it
too much but like
so you guys became how did you really
because you didn't so much together that
i'm like
you must really like each other you have
a podcast kings of kong you did the show
kings of khan right and you did a show
kings of khan
and he did another show that was
formerly before kings of khan
talking with richard or some [ __ ] right
right so we uh
yeah we um did uh we actually uh raised
money and did a
um a show uh on comic-con had a
fledgling uh network web website that
had
it was gate was the big 800 pound
gorilla behind that but
bad boy yeah lionsgate uh did you know
original content and we uh we produced a
show
for that network uh 10 episodes called
kings of khan was that with alan tudyk
and nathan fillion
that was at the same time exact same
time funny story about them
some funny story about that is we wrote
the show we called it
uh con men and and it was about you know
it was the same
the idea was it was rich and i doing the
conventions and we're not famous
anywhere else but at the conventions
and you know like you know we're only
famous like
you know 12 weekends a year that was our
that was the the
tagline in the poster meet rob and rich
these two men are super famous 13
weekends a year
right and and you know and that the
craziest people at the conventions
are the actors themselves and so we we
did this video and raised this
and did a an online campaign to raise
some money
and before sort of about to release it
to the world
the like press came out with this this
press release that nathan fillion uh
had this new show um and it was called
con man well that was there just to put
a final point on it we were launching
our crowdfunding campaign
they launched their crowdfunding
campaign that's right that's what it was
yeah they launched their crowdfunding
campaign and broke records
like they just smashed goals and it was
a great
really well executed campaign and we
were literally about to hit send on ours
had to scramble back and re-title
everything because we were they were con
man and we were con men
i mean it was just one of those things
where they had the same idea same name
and we're doing it better than us you
know my friend dax once said and you
know name drop but like he does have
some good advice every once in a while
but he said rosie
if you're a janitor and you have this
idea
about being a janitor on toilets don't
you think other janitors have thought
about this idea with toilets and
whatever it is it's like we're actors we
have ideas whatever we're doing we have
an idea we go to conventions oh wouldn't
it be cool there's probably a lot of
actors that have come up with these
ideas
having your own twist timing having
people back you
all these other things are out of our
control and it sucks but
um but you did 10 episodes and you loved
it and it was uh
well you know we had this that we had we
we had a come to jesus talk we're like
because my instinct is always like well
[ __ ] it we got beat
we're we're done and you know rich was
like listen man
this it's the same i you know we're the
chicago hope to their er
there's no reason that the world can't
have two shows like this
yeah we are ourselves there's no way
we're going to be them we are have our
own unique take on it
let's rename it and [ __ ] forge ahead
and that's what we did and we're proud
of what we
we created these 10 episodes are on a
pretty small budget
are we think really funny and really
hold up available on amazon prime
amazon prime i mean look there was
leviathan there was the abyss at the
same time there was exactly
there's always there's 9-1-1 with
swapped
and there's right you know you're right
there's uh you know if you have a uh
enough of a fan base or um you know but
i'm glad you went through with it and
you shot the ten episodes and yeah guys
you should check that out
but you guys yeah it's it's it's funny
it's it you know stars a lot of our
friends from supernatural
um sort of an homage to the to what our
actual experiences are but uh
you know but i'll say this this show is
made
but for any of you anybody listening who
thinks you know well i don't know
conventions i won't enjoy the show
my pitchfork is always you don't have to
have been a writer on snl to have
enjoyed 30 rock
you don't have to know conventions
because it's a situational comedy the
the characters and the situations are
what drive it the wallpaper is unique in
that it's a convention world
um but you know you come for the
convention you stay for the haha and the
haha
is the characters and how they interact
[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by geico
uh everybody knows this word geico you
hear it all the time
but uh there's a reason why they're a
big name in insurance and all these
other things because uh
you know they just they're everywhere
and they they know what they're doing
um ryan you you rent your place we've
talked about this
and you own your home right and we just
we talked about this but it's just a
pain in the
arse when you have to go pay your auto
policy
your home policy you're this you're that
and that's why geico is wonderful
and they have bundling policies
bundling policies with geico geico makes
it easy to bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance
along with your auto policy it's a good
thing too
because you already have too much to do
around your home so go to geico.com
get a quote and see how much you could
save
it's guy co-easy visit geico.com today
that's geico geico.com even a rosenbomb
can do it inside of you is brought to
you by butcherbox i love these guys
there's nothing better than getting a
box
full of fresh freaking meat to your
doorstep
you know ryan i made these short ribs
for my friend rob you know rob
rob danson i said you want some short
ribs he's like yeah we're reordering
i go we're not ordering it's butcher box
you're gonna make them heck yeah they
gave me these right this rack
of ribs it was huge
in this box and i bathed it basked it
in barbecue sauce and i just
i cooked the crap out of that thing and
it was just awesome it's just delicious
and i don't and i'm not a
great cook but i could grill i could
throw a piece of meat on there
on the grill and uh it was just
delicious their meats are truly
exceptional
and i think that's why people are really
excited about them every time i mention
them people are like oh yeah i know
butcher box
you know spring is here it's it's here
i'd say
and uh you know we're doing the spring
cleaning and uh you know rear
arranging things and getting rid of junk
taking care of your space ryan but you
know you also got to take care of what
you put on your plate
and that is a nice piece of meat
juicy delicious meat
and butcher box uh they have just
really made me happy with the things
they have sent me with butcher box you
get the highest quality meat around for
just
six dollars a meal and they even have
free shipping nationwide except for
alaska
and hawaii each box has 10 pounds
of meat enough for 24 individual meals
packed fresh shipped frozen
vacuum sealed so it stays that way right
now butcher box is offering new members
ground beef
for life that's two pounds of ground
beef in every box for the life of your
subscription
all you gotta do is just go to
butcherbox.com
inside that's butcherbox.com
inside you are going to love butcher box
wasn't it dick spate jr that's sitting
right here with me
isn't he the guy that brought you to the
hospital rob when you had the stroke
many moons ago
yeah when you're asking about the uh
when you're asking about our friendship
you know we we in like 2011 or something
we did a convention in rome
and that's i think when we were like it
went beyond like oh that guy that i kind
of know it was like oh i really
like it was you know you meet certain
people in your life that you're like oh
wow
this guy really gets it like i get it
and we're getting it in the same way and
our humor was
you know my brother likened it to like
playing basketball with
someone that's just really easy to do
you throw a no hook pat
no look pass and they're right there you
know that kind of thing yeah
and uh we kept getting paired together
after that at conventions because we
we jive together so well um but then
yeah our and then
our relationship definitely took another
step forward when uh
he he uh got me to that he was a guy
that got me to hospital i mean i was
having a stroke and
uh obviously that was the last thing
that anyone thought was actually
happening and
rich had the wherewithal to did he call
you you were in your hotel room didn't
he call you up
you want to take that rich it was uh so
it was in toronto
and we were all gonna go have a steak
after wrapping it up on sunday
and so the group jared jensen miesha uh
cliff
myself and we were gonna go and rob
it was on that that list of people were
going to walk across the street like
it's like down the block
and go have a steak which we've done the
year before kind of a
thing we did in toronto and rob was
still signing autographs we left so i
will just meet you there robbie and you
kind of like all right
waves is on we're waiting we're waiting
we're waiting
and i text him
you know hey we're waiting and he's like
not feeling it
and that is like did not sound like rob
like not
feeling it like we've been busting our
hump for 72 hours you're not going to
come
what so i called him and i said hey
we're
we're all waiting we're not going to
order until you get here because we
don't want you know we're
get out of here i'll order your martini
and and he was like i
should just i i don't know i mean what
do you mean you don't know
i got a feeling you know i'm like dude
you're stressed
yeah i know you you're around like a
banjo string you probably all you know
you know riddled with anxiety get up get
out of the eye of the storm
come on go over here and he's like no
i don't know and i can do it and we hung
up and i was like
none of that made sense to me and i
can't explain why i just went back to
the guys and i said
this doesn't make sense man i'm going
back i'm going to the hotel this is not
something doesn't make sense it just
didn't sound right it just
like and i always make the joke i've
never known rob to turn down a free
martini
but that's the simple way of saying it
but it was like there's just something
not right the way he was phrasing it
the energy that i know we just had in
the middle of the day and we were
planning on this and just to do a 180
like that
i'm like it's like like when a 911
person knows oh there's somebody with a
gun to this person's head on the
other line of the other end of the phone
i should send the cops like
it was just a weird moment was he
mumbling at all was he was he was it a
mumble kind of like slurred speech
he was just an indecisive he wasn't
slurring he he
and i know this sounds again like a bit
but rob's own
sort of natural speech pattern and
remember it was going to progress and
get worse as the night went on but at
this moment
his natural speech patter pattern
lent itself to not revealing what was
going on
his sort of you know comedic like ah you
know
i mean really you know that
became the speech pattern but he wasn't
coming out of it it was like
he would just just keep doing that as
opposed to
rich i'm not feeling good man i gotta
lay down i'm shot
that's a sentence i could go oh okay but
it was more like
ash ah you know
just i just feel i don't know man and
you're like
okay you know it just didn't seem right
it just didn't seem right so you went to
the hotel
you did you go up to the room i went to
the hotel went to the room and there was
one of the handlers there
who had walked him back to his room and
she
looked concerned i'm like what we have
handlers walking us to and from our
rooms
and she's like i don't know man he just
seemed out of it at the end of the
autograph session
i'm like okay i'll go talk to him and
she goes but he doesn't want anybody in
there and they're like well i'm going in
there
and and i went in there and it's talking
to him and he's like i
don't know man i just blah blah blah
you know kind of him and haun i'm like
okay and i said dude are you okay he's
like i just you know
and i thought he was having an anxiety
attack you know i thought something had
gotten
gotten him worked up and i'm like i
this is okay this is odd there's a
there's a guy who's a sound guy
who had a has a you know he's a
practicing physician anymore everybody
had been
and i said you know i told the gals like
maybe go grab him and bring him up here
meanwhile i'm talking to him and he's
like i just want to watch the you know
the game i'm like okay cool football
game
and i call misha it's mitch's phone and
i'm like something right this
that something's this is not right uh
i'm gonna have to hang here
you know and he's like
misha's like put him on the phone so put
him on the phone with misha misha talked
to him for a second
and he got on the phone he's like yeah
something's not right because the way
rob was hammering and haunting
and i was like rob who's the quarterback
of the team you're playing who you you
know who's that guy
you know and i'm like dude doesn't know
like he's not saying anything and i'm
going to hurry he's like could it be a
stroke and i'm like
i don't know but it ain't right and the
doc came
up sat with him had him talked to him
for a little bit had to do a few tests
and he said
it's not a stroke he's having an anxiety
attack
let's let him sleep it off i said okay
and he left the room
and i'm like that dude's wrong i'm not
do i'm not
i'm not leaving the hospital what i
wanted to do was sleep i just remember
the time i just wanted to sleep and i
was like dude
i gotta take you to the doctor and
you're like no no i don't go to the
doctor i'm like i know
i'm the [ __ ] if i'm wrong
dinner's on me but i gotta take you down
if he
would have slept and you would have said
fine because a lot of people it's a long
day you're out with your friends you're
thinking of things you want to go out
for drink watch football
you go eyes tired most of the time it's
just fatigue it's anxiety
i get that if you let rob go to sleep we
might not have rob
is that fair to say yes yeah
at the very least i i may not you know
may never have
been able to speak i mean it was it was
i was losing words
and i couldn't what he i think what he
really
saw was that i was having a hard time
putting anything together putting words
together right it wasn't comic stick
anymore like i was like didn't i put
didn't i did i when i was watching the
game didn't i like
call the football a banana or something
like that that's something i remember i
can't i wish i could remember exactly
what it was it was also something in
that framework now this at this point
i've already said we're going to the
doctor i already leaned out and i said
girls get a car not an ambulance get a
car we're driving to the hospital we're
not going to make a scene
we're just gonna get out of here and so
they were wrestling up a car
and you're sitting there and you you
used a word incorrectly
dramatically so like oh he just uh
scored a bookshelf and you're like yeah
man
okay like you know he did something with
the word replacement
that you're like right and then we go to
the hospital and this is the thing that
was
so i'm still thinking and rob you'd leap
in any time man
i know it's your story but i just like
i'm still thinking
i'm wrong it's anxiety i'm being overly
cautious here but you know what i'm
gonna err on caution but in my mind i'm
like
you know how this plays out you get over
there and you find out your body's got
indigestion
not a heart problem like you know
whatever
and we get over there and
there's a pretty full waiting room like
there would be in any emergency room
and we go up to sign in
and i go hey my buddy here is having a
hard time like putting thoughts together
and
i don't know maybe nothing but a little
concerned and she goes okay what's his
name
and i go or what's your name and i go
it's rob benedict she's like no no i
need him to talk to me
uh what's your name and you go and
immediately she's pushing a button under
the table
like immediately i see her pushing
something and
five seconds later while he's going rob
benedict
four doctors walk out turns out
by accident we're at toronto's premier
stroke center hospital
it happened to be the closest hospital
we went to and she hit the button
and the stroke team was in the waiting
room
standing next to rob waiting room full
of people and like they're like nope
you're sir you're on a gurney boom and
we're going and we're like
whoa okay oh man i just got emotional
too i i don't know right when you said
the button thing i don't know i got a
little emotional that's
that's just overwhelming oh man holy
[ __ ] do you remember the button part rob
or is that
did only i see that part i think just
you saw saw that
but uh yeah i know i just remember
getting a cat scan pretty much right
away
and just thinking what the [ __ ] is going
on you know
i kept thinking this has gotta be sounds
kind of weird yeah it doesn't mean yeah
i was 43.
doesn't it doesn't make any sense and um
i don't have high
cholesterol you know nothing like that
no history
you know healthy weight like there's no
telltale signs which by the way
cautionary tale anybody listening there
are no telltale signs a stroke could hit
a young fella you know what i mean the
signs are you know the signs they talk
about like if
speech is slurred or face is drooping
you can't lift one arm
go to the hospital right away because
time is of the essence you have to
capture get it right away because you're
getting
you're having a blood loss to your brain
um and so
then what then these doctors around my
my around me
back in this room this is how i remember
it and this really strict kind of
doctor's like you're
so you're having a stroke uh we need to
give you this medication
this blood clot buster right that's uh
but there's an 11 17 chance
i remember i think there's a 14 chance
it kills you
it kills you and and i remember the dude
coming out i'll never forget this this
was like a moment
man i'm standing there i'm as close to
next to canada as he's got
you know at this moment and rob's in the
bed and i'm standing there and the
doctor
who by the way is not a stand-up
comedian i get it right real cold
like he's a stroke guy you know his
bedside manner is
i'm gonna give you the facts and you
need to tell me an answer right now
quickly
and they're wrap and rob an iv around
his around his
his arm and they're getting a needle in
the whole thing and he's like here's
what's going on you're having a stroke
you have this percent of brain damage
right now the medicine you need i can't
remember the name of it off the top of
my head but it's a very common stroke
emergency
medication the medicine you need uh
i need to give to you right now um it
does
there's a 30 chance it does nothing
there's a you know 50 percent chance
it will uh you know 55
chance it it will improve reduce the
damage
and there's a 14 to 15 percent chance it
will kill you
it'll cause it'll you'll cause more
bleeding in your brain and you're you'll
bleed out and they need to know that
now yeah and and rob goes molly
and i said i think he wants to call his
wife
molly and he looked at rob and he goes
molly can't help you right now
and i was like whoa and i remember rob
and i looked at each other and we both
started laughing
because it was like crisis laughter i
was like [ __ ]
like this ain't a bit man this guy just
said there's a 15
chance and i'm like are you wrapping his
arm to give him the drug right now i am
as soon as he nods his head yes
is he on if he were unconscious i would
have already given him the drug he's
conscious so by law i have to get his
approval the second he nods yes
we're pushing in the drugs and we'll
find out in 48 hours if it does nothing
if it helps or if it kills him and i was
like i remember looking at rob and i'm
like
yeah rich is like crying at this point
rich starts crying and that's where and
i really was like i'm
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] this is really
[ __ ] and
uh so uh yeah we're laughing and crying
and
uh i finally just kind of nod my head
and they give you the shot and they give
it to me and it helped obviously and
and i was lucky it it it did it yeah i
mean i mean
it brought you the rob oh the other
thing the guy said was
he's like if i don't give you the
medicine you will keep getting worse
or you'll stay like you are and that's
no way to live
because at this point rob couldn't speak
at this point rob like if rob was frozen
and that
if that was the new normal for rob he's
learning everything over again
and it was intense like that guy was
saying that guy was not that guy was not
pulling punches thank god because the
clock's ticking you know he didn't have
time for the
[ __ ] there's no hand holding it's
like i need an answer
i need an answer 10 minutes ago so rob
and yeah go ahead i'm sorry
go ahead that's it i mean like it was
just it was just such an intense
experience
is intense you know obviously more for
rob than than
than for me but nonetheless but rob so
you know we know obviously the rest is
history and you you improved and you
took a lot of work and you had to really
work on speech therapy and things like
that right
yeah yeah yeah and it kind of got worse
before it got better it was 48 hours in
the icu it was
kind of terrifying i mean i'm shaking
right now just sort of talking about
just because it just
it it it doesn't go it doesn't go away
it was it was a life-altering moment uh
traumatic uh but yeah i know it got
worse before it got
better and kind of had to slowly learn
to speak again
or just the words just slowly started
their their advice was just to keep
talking
um kept trying to get me to talk what do
you do
what do you do now to sort of uh
prevent is there anything you could do
to prevent other than eating well or
doing the best you can
is it is it one thing does the doctor
just say
rob you're okay now you're fully healthy
you're recovered
chances are this isn't gonna happen
again you just need to go live your life
and not worry about it
that's exactly what he said yeah when i
got i got back that was in toronto right
so i was i was there for
you know a couple weeks and then i
finally flew home
um saw the doctors here
um and then uh you know it took a couple
months i was in speech therapy and then
also my carotid
artery still wasn't working over here
um because that's where i had this tear
in my carotid artery
so that's where your pulse is and you've
got two carotid arteries
so this one on the left i had no pulse
over here because it did shut down
and um that's a scary way to live too
because that means if this one goes down
you're you're done
right so in toronto they said that would
never heal
but the doctor here said you had 50
chance it could heal and a couple months
later it actually did heal
my my blood started flowing on this side
again
so besides i you know i get a sonogram
every couple of years just to make sure
there's no plaque in there my carotid is
working
um i used to take blood thinners and
then i stopped doing that and just start
taking aspirin
low dose of aspirin every day and then i
stopped doing that so
yeah the doctor said live your life he
was like you know don't be stupid don't
don't go on roller coasters don't don't
do anything that's gonna jostle your
your neck around
because that's really what it was it was
like i had my some
some for some reason my carotid artery
tore
so he's like don't no no high contact
physical sports
you know i don't i don't go upside down
i used to do like
upside down against the wall you know
like at my workouts and stuff i don't do
that anymore how often do you think
about it
uh in in a year every day
every day you still think about it yes
absolutely 100 percent
and and it just it just never go i mean
you know i i i with the older you get
you you it's hard to remember certain
things i feel like for me that's worse
than it used to be it's always part of
getting older but also just like every
time
i don't remember something i'm having a
conversation rich knows i mean
all the time like what's what's the
thing the the or who's the guy or what
you know every time i'm like oh [ __ ]
is it happening because it's it was that
what was so terrifying about is it was i
was rich is right it was like i was
stuck
i was stuck in that mode of looking for
a word and no word ever came
and so every time i forget a word or
something i think
about that you know the next word just
doesn't come to me
well look i appreciate the story it's
it's just captain i was looking at my uh
my buddy my partner over here my
engineer uh ryan and he's just like
he had never heard of him and he's just
like awesome just like wow and it is an
amazing story and it just
it really will help people though to you
know just
if they're going through it or if
they've experienced or whatever or they
have an experience it's something
it's a wake-up call and it's something
you can't control and it's just uh
it's life and it's like you survived it
and uh you owe everything to richard
spate
so no no no no but look so this whole
story this friendship
if anything kind of cemented this
friendship forever
it's you know that that moment you know
i
without having to ask you about other
things about experiences but
it brings us to you know this awesome
podcast which i was just on the kings of
khan
which is is so much fun and you have so
much of a following
how did this happen why did you want to
do another podcast with all the other
actors and all the things that are going
on
this is just something you thought this
is easy let's just do it for us or did
you think
let's do it maybe you know we have
enough fans maybe people will listen i
mean
who whose idea who's the mastermind
behind it
rob i can't rise baby yeah i kind of had
to convince rich to do it
um at the beginning of lockdown i was
like look we're locked down
what if what if the the idea is that
every every week you're my guest
and it was called and my guess is
richard spade which made me laugh
immediately i'm like i'm in
that's funny it's also like the the
fleetwood mac thing on snl right he
never gets to
you know one up with that one up with
that she said he said my guess is from
fleetwood mac
it is uh lindsey buckingham and they
never get to lindsey buckingham and
people are like most people like who's
lindsey buckingham unless you're us who
know lindsey buckingham
yeah anyway i love that too but so then
it became kings of khan
and then became kings of khan and and
you know now we have guests at first
there were no guests except rich and now
we have guests like you on
and uh and it became kings of khan
because we were doing it
like everybody we know yourself included
michael um
rob and i can't sit still man like we're
dudes who gotta be doing something no
and we want to be doing something fun
and creative and if it's not standing on
a stage with a live mic making jokes at
each other's expense it's right in the
script and if it's not written the
script it's like
ooh let's just shoot something fun with
their phones if we're not doing that
it's like
let's at least have a beer and make sure
to laugh can't do that because of
lockdown
so it became well let's just do this and
if our audience is just
us fine well you know rob will write
some music we'll have a few laughs
that'll be the bit and it became so
organic
to both of us we both started enjoying
it so much and
building an audience that we're like we
actually had a couple dudes who actually
do it for living
friends of ours go like build it up a
little bit like like get give yourself
some bandwidth to expand
so it's not just and richard spate
because right now you're playing for an
audience people who have to know who
richard spade is to get the joke versus
if you open it up to yeah it could be
just you guys but also
you actually have a reach of people and
you have experiences and you can
tap into that for comedic effect and and
and use
the baseline of conventions to have
people coming out use your known brand
to to get
guests involved you know what else is
wonderful about that is that
you can it's also a platform for you to
have direct communication with your with
your fans and your friends and your
family where
you're talking about things that they
maybe relate to you're telling them hey
if you want to see us play here it's
like
it's something like hey we're going to
go in and be part of this family for an
hour
and you know and they could follow you
whatever you're doing it's
instead of just posting all the time
you're talking to them and you're saying
they feel like they
know you and they do know you and uh so
that that's
there's something nice about that it's
cool and and you know i guess come on
talk about whatever they want but rob
and i early on
were like look we want to talk to people
but we would only talk show hosts that's
not what we want to do
the goal is talk to people
and our sort of comedic business plan
was if people listen to our podcast
and learn anything about our guests we
haven't done our job
like it should it should be our goal is
just have a good time
if something spills out great if it's
just a laugh
and people feel like oh i just listened
in on three buddies having a beer
great that's also the goal like it's
whatever it is
it was it was so enjoyable and you guys
have such a good rapport and the back
and forth
it did it was just like that's how i
like to do this podcast more like a
conversation and if things kind of come
out
they come out and like you add little
things and who's i'm sorry i can't think
of her name she's on the show with you
tina tina i love tina she was great and
she has her
role and you guys have your roles and
then rob does this thing where he's like
all right what's your pick a genre of
music and i said 90s and he's like all
right pick someone you want to talk
about i go
my grandma blanche and it was genius and
you did this little song about my
grandmother
in the style of eddie vetter and you you
have a just a fun
it's just you know what it is if nothing
else i just want to hang out with you
guys and i said that before this
today's podcast i thought i really just
like these guys i i i would love
nothing more than i can't wait to to
just sit down with you
or play guitar with you and have a beer
or you know make sure it's before 9 00
pm
for richard and you're just two lovable
[ __ ] good guys in an industry that
seems like there's a lot of darkness and
yet you're the light at the end of the
tunnel and i appreciate that and your
candor and your openness and your
you know you telling these stories and
it's just it just
i i enjoy the [ __ ] out of it and you
know a lot of people will think you know
who's michael rosebomb who's richard
spate who's rob benedict
well when they listen to you they like
you yeah
you're likable and i think that's a big
part of it
thank you thank you and same goes to you
buddy we feel the same
we are blessed with and i do think the
industry
can draw draw from society some some
not great people but there are great
people in there if you take the time to
look and listen and find them and
you know we're all journeymen we've all
been at this a long time
we all have our our battle scars and our
trophies and our
are almost almost wins and are also rans
and i think when you when you chalk up
that kind of history and have it in your
saddlebag and keep mosing across the
desert you meet some interesting
wanderers along the way
yeah and you are one of them and it is
and rob is one of them and
i think it's i think we're lucky to to
still be still be on our horse
i love it and then by the way thank you
for allowing me to talk uh about my uh
my album on your on your uh podcast that
was nice absolutely
thank you they this is called uh
benedick and spates [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
talking with benedick and spate
this is rapid fire these are my patrons
who get to ask questions
rapid fire you could both say it's cindy
h favorite city
spate sorry favorite city yeah nashville
tennessee
benedict chicago illinois great lisa h i
love the short
lived show kings of con brilliant
concept how true were the character
personalities to the real rob and rich
rich uh half true half um made up
yeah comedic versions of our actual
selves
leanne p who are some of your favorite
heroes benedict
like real heroes or for facebook well
you're personal heroes it could be
anybody
okay um
personal heroes um
my brother that's right
yeah he became my sort of father after
my dad left which was
a lot for him to handle but uh yeah i
really dig my bro
that's awesome rich skip muk the man i
played in
vander brothers who was a real world war
ii veteran who lost his life during
battle the bulge
getting to know about him through his
family was a life-changing experience
and my high school football coach tommy
owen i learned more about acting from
tommy owen
than i ever did for any other acting
teacher thomas owen
rozzie what are the funniest things that
have happened to you both
to both of you on set of supernatural
rich
rapid fire uh i had my mouth sewn shut
as a character
so they had to glue my mouth shut and
for the rest of the day people made
open fun of me because i couldn't
respond rob
um uh on the set of supernatural
um i got to hit uh jared padilecki with
uh a plunger and uh and i kept getting
it wrong so he got multiple takes so
that was super fun
getting to hit a guy a 6'5
dude with a plunger like 10 times
angie this one's for rob if you haven't
already please share your naked
acupuncture story
i mean it's a long story but basically
the short version is that
i never been to an acupuncturist before
and uh i went this year he had me get
naked
uh you could see the front door opening
and i on the podcast with rich him and
tina i was like
is is this normal this happened to me is
this normal they're like no
that's not normal that's just weird
rachel harrison is our guest and rachel
like literally was like
flummoxed it was not normal it's not
normal that's weird
i've never had that yeah this is from
aisha
can you guys give a little aisha
what have you learned about each other
working on your podcast together
rob um
that uh rich uh has a really good radio
voice
uh and but yeah but that he's not
technically sound
right that's funny i was gonna say
here's what i learned rob's way more
technically savvy than i am
and can write write and record music
very quickly is a quick turnaround on
his
musical creativity rich give me a little
dj voice close to the camera where you
say
you're listening to the inside of you
podcast uh you're listening to inside of
you with michael rosenbaum with
superstars rob benedict and richard
spade
you're listening to michael rosenbaum's
star studded podcast inside of you
with special guest rob benedict and
richard spate jr
go inside these two and see why so
freaking dark
so freaking dark i love that i always
wanted to be
a dj i was a dj in college for i i might
have an okay dj timber
but i have the addiction of a man who's
had his jaw broken a few times and so
like
i might have somewhere in the register
of a dj voice
but sort of my half lisp and shitty
diction to prevent me
i've never done a radio commercial
nothing because as soon as i get in like
oh nice start richard spade okay do the
product
cry delicious
i think you have a great voice though i
always thought dj voice be cool
i always wonder how they are at home
though 99.5 wkdq
listening to the hits of yesterday and
today another 30 minute music marathon
uh right now uh i wonder how they are at
home though right
sweetheart how was your day it was great
honey how are you how was your day
you just got to be the weirdest i love
my sons love slash hate it because i do
my morning dj voice a lot back when
i'd be driving them to school i'd be
like hey
the roads are back to people in hong
kong we're getting our way to nine
o'clock in the morning
time to wake up check out the vlog cause
you gotta get to school don't be a fool
get out there and learn
right now this hot trash oh hey i listen
i love the hell out of both you i wish
you continued success
i can't wait to see and hold you and uh
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of both you today
thanks i appreciate the invitation
and i want to leave this great story
with one
tidbit a circle if you think you are
with somebody who's having a medical
concern
and that medical concern is out of your
realm of understanding
err on the side of caution and seek
medical
treatment take them to a doctor if
you're wrong
you buy lunch but it's always better to
be safe
rather than sorry because rob and i are
living testaments to the fact that you
don't always know what's going on
and trust your instincts if it feels
weird probably is weird
take them to the doctor beautiful yeah i
love that
there's a there's a there's a something
to remember uh with strokes called fast
uh face arms
uh speech and
tongue or time uh the different ways you
can tell if someone's having a stroke if
their face is drooping
if their their arm won't raise if their
speech is slurry
uh or their tongue uh like my tongue it
would go to the one side
just it would if i stuck my tongue out
it wouldn't go straight down or go to
one side
and and time because you got to get them
to the hospital fast i love it
thank you for all the insight i love you
both and uh i'll talk to you soon
yeah all right thanks buddy thank you
buddy thanks for having us
man you're right that was a good one
ryan yeah it was it was uh
i mean if if if richard didn't
you know a lot of times i'll say to a
friend you know we're at a hotel or
something he's like
i'm too tired or i'm too tired no one
checks up on me
i say hey i'm gonna go to my room
whatever you know
let me know when they text and i say
yeah i'm not up to it they leave me
alone
but there was something that that spate
felt that there was something off about
rob and
i'm so grateful for richard spate
for for you know just being there and
giving extra attention
and um just trusting his gut and because
i love rob benedict so much
he's such a wonderful human being that i
love that he's part of my life and uh
what'd you get get from this i mean
that's just an incredible
story and like how lucky well uh
how lucky to have a friend like that
yeah
like that's just it's just a triumph of
friendship and it made me feel really
warm and fuzzy inside yeah that richard
was willing to
go the extra mile and just like the
whole
yeah the whole thing it's and i i mean
because i related to it a little bit
uh i mean i wasn't oh yeah that wasn't
threatened but i had a seizure on the
on a beach once that's right let's let's
hear that
um so i was at uh it was a bachelor
party for my friend we went to san diego
we had an airbnb um and so the night
before was our was our drink night and
so we you know went
down the town had a lot of san diego
beers got up uh
and i did not drink enough water um and
these are all my surfer friends too so
they wanted to go into the ocean
uh in the morning and so i just sort of
took a boogie board
and a wetsuit and just sort of and it
wasn't it was a crazy riptide day so we
were just getting
tossed around just exhausted and so we
were just it was just the day of like
trying to like work out like sweat out
the beers of last night and then just
like
sweating in the wetsuit and we just had
a bunch of coffee
during the day just to try to wake up
and then we were about to
um go to dinner just go have like a nice
easy dinner
uh we were also all sort of feeling
sleepy so we decided to go on the beach
and play spike ball you know spike ball
is
yeah it's like the game where you like
you smack a ball and into the the
circular net and we were having a great
time doing that earlier in the week um
and we thought let's you know let's just
do a little fun thing and then we'll
shower and then we'll go to dinner
uh and me just being uh super
competitive and diving for balls
and i was just too dehydrated and a
perfect storm of all the fatigue the
alcohol of coffee so it was just it was
just like spinning and like i was like
you know it was weird because like i was
like when the butt when the game stopped
i was like
just sort of warped and then um when i
you know when the game was playing i was
like able to move around and hit balls
and things but then
at a certain point the lights just went
out just went out just went out just
stopped
and you had a seizure uh and apparently
i had a seizure
and it was just a crazy dehydration and
so what i'm grateful for and what i
think about
with the the robin richards story is uh
my friend chase
who is now a fireman for l.a county uh
and at the time was an emt
he's just one of those guys who's just
he he's great in crisis moments
he just hit the button like let's go
he's got to go i
apparently i fell into his arms he was
like that on it he was just and then he
just sort of he knew exactly what to do
he kept me from like biting my tongue
um and just uh what do you do that how
do you do that i mean
like yeah
tilted or something oh yeah and then i
got yeah i got transferred to
la jolla hospital and that was the end
of the bachelor party chase
thank you chase thank you richard spate
thank you chase
for saving ryan and thank you stefan for
being cool with me ruining your bachelor
party
oh sorry bud yeah what a dick move dude
that guy has a seizure during us
seriously like you could help that yep
well we could have
i think yeah but you know you always
think you're indestructible when you're
young right
yeah well this was four years ago four
years ago
yeah yeah that wasn't you were well
you're young still yeah
jesus man that's that's it scares me
because you never know what's going to
happen you just never know what you're
about how your body's going to react in
your body every we have a threshold
everybody and you don't know what that
is and some people are indestructible
or seem so and anyway thanks for
listening
to today's podcast i want to thank
everybody and uh
please please subscribe if you're still
listening uh it truly helps
and uh the handles on twitter and
instagram at insightyoupodcast on the
instagram
insideoupod on the twitter and facebook
and um
go to youtube subscribe uh and wherever
you listen
for write a review if you can uh the
inside of you online store
20 off just for about 24 hours that's it
uh the code word password is inside
ryan 20. that's correct so
uh get some good merch we've got
smallville lunch boxes available we've
got
i believe some beanies um some lex
luthor shirts bunch of
cool inside shirts lots of stuff
and also the band sunspin.com for all
your delicious needs
um you can get this sweet cd signed by
rob and i and a bunch of other stuff
we've got
at sunspin.com also a big shout out to
all my wonderful charities that i love
foodonfoot.org
really helping homeless people across
los angeles and
they could always use your support if
you want to donate or become a 98
club member foodonfoot.org
also the ronald mcdonald house of los
angeles i love those guys
they do real good stuff and echoes of
hope for foster
youth so echoesofhope.org as well
those are the charities that i
contribute to and love
i'm going to read off the wonderful
patrons who make this podcast very
possible they're a big part of that
also a big shout out to westwood one
thank you
for believing in the show thank you ryan
for working diligently
and coming out with great stuff and
really great editing and uh
love love having you here and uh bryce
bryce who works non-stop on the podcast
trying to get people like you to listen
and you're listening uh here are the
patrons
top tier patrons who uh you if you want
to join patreon it's a wonderful family
i say it all the time just go to
patreon.com inside
and uh join the family today uh it's
wonderful you get great perks
um certain tiers get uh to ask the guest
questions um
they get a merch box with a note from me
um youtube lives where i play music and
people have a request line open it's fun
it's all good it's all good all right
here they are here
are the top tier patrons i feel like
david letterman it's like the top ten
in the top ten you know i miss i missed
that nancy d
mary b leah asked trisha sarah v
little lisa yukiko jill e brian h
lauren g nico p robin asked jerry w
robert i jason w
uh apothean apithean mm-hmm it's a new
one
it was last time yeah apathy and
epithelium
apathy ooh rodney apathy and apathy and
apathy
sorry kristen k amelia oh
alison l jess j wow i couldn't do this
lucas m raj c joshua d
emily s cjt samantha m jennifer and
jackie p
stacy l carly h carly s jen
s jamal f janelle b carrie b tabitha
272. not going to be confused with kevin
the 273.
ashley ryan kimberly e mike mikey
marissa and el don supremo that's dan
jack slater ramirez
beth b santiago m sarah half chad w liam
p
rey a maya p maisha
maddie s kendrick f ashley f shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v james r chris
h
osborne osborne h
amy c dave h samantha s spider-man
chase sheila g rey hey
yes melissa c tap with the t misha aged
tom
a n tom n tommen tom and henry
s kdf liliana a michelle k hannah b
a few more and then we're uh we're good
but here are the uh the last of the
wonderful patrons
this is michael s talia m luke h john s
andrew t
uh claire baby hey claire baby
liz j laura l chad l rochelle nathan e
brandel taylor k
neil a marion meg k
janelle p dan and jennifer j wayne
m diana r ojeda ogetta
lorraine g olga c corey m carrie h
veronica k and big stevie
w oh big stevie
those are the uh wonderful patrons
stevie wonder st it's stevie wonder oh
my god
stevie won my god uh thank you so much
from um
my my from myself michael and and and
myself ryan
myself his self ryan here in the
hollywood hills
california hey everybody 95 degrees
partly cloudy how could it be 95 degrees
and partly cloudy
it seems like it has to be full sun
i don't get it oh man it's almost
baseball season oh i know it's almost
baseball season
um much love to everybody out there give
away old ryan
and uh we'll see you on the flip side
thank you for allowing me to be
inside each and every one of you okay
we'll see
[Music]